johnny depp appeared slightly more
relaxed as the libel trial resumed for a
second week he and his ex-wife amber
heard who are suing each other over an
article she wrote about domestic
violence both returned to the virginia
courtroom depp's personal doctor read a
long list of disorders he's been
treating the actor for
primary dopamine imbalance adhd which is
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
bipolar one
depression secondary to above insomnia
chronic substance abuse disorder
he described finding depth with the tip
of his fingers sliced off following a
ride between the couple in australia how
long did you attend mr death outside of
the house
not long probably
a half hour i needed to get him to the
emergency room
i went in to instruct
one of the
people with him
to look for the tip of the finger
hoping that we would be able to put it
back
was the tip of the finger found
it was found
who found it
i believe this man was their chef
and do you know where he found it or
where he told you he found it
he said he found it in the kitchen area
the doctor said he'd never witnessed
johnny depp physically abuse amber heard
and he'd never treated her for any
injury depp who's expected to give
evidence today is suing his ex-wife for
50 million dollars alleging she defamed
him in the article she's countersuing
him for 100 million dollars alleging he
defamed her by describing her claims as
fake
david blevins sky news washington